the Joe Rogan experience is it a startup
he said female do you knows Lee I was
reading all the people that invested
hundreds of millions of dollars into
that scam blood test company that blood
test company story is crazy theranos
there was this woman and they were
calling her like the next Steve Jobs but
the steel just the female Steve Jobs she
even dressed like I'm sure black
turtlenecks really yeah and she she had
become this self-made person drew I
think from college started this company
and then by the time she was like forty
whatever she was when they they busted
her she was worth thirty four billion
dollars because this blood testing thing
that she had developed and then as time
went on they realized that it didn't
really work and that all these people
had invested like Betsey Davos I think
it was and Warren Buffett had Warren
Buffett invested over a hundred million
dollars in twenty five yeah in this
company that it was it was [ __ ] so
these they put these people's health at
risk because they gave them these tests
and the test didn't work and they're
showing that they kind of knew the test
didn't work but this is how this woman
dressed all the time it's um it's really
interesting man it's a really
interesting story because when you see
the amount of money that people invested
into it and then they're just [ __ ] out
of luck she went from being worth I
think she was worth something crazy like
the richest woman ever are the richest
self-made woman ever something along
those lines I think she was worth like
thirty four billion dollars at one point
she's a Twitter yeah and then she's
recently been charged with massive fraud
I don't know I mean I don't know [ __ ]
about that business so I don't know if
the blood test did or didn't work or if
she's got a store that needs to be told
and I don't know we just just read what
you read and what you read is that they
they've fibbed about results and they
they did some [ __ ] that they shouldn't
have done and all these people got tests
and they thought they were you know if
you get a blood test you think you're
getting the accurate results from a
reputable company and it wasn't it was a
micro click like they would take like a
micro
prick of blood and they would take that
blood and they would measure it and
that's how they would find whether you
had disease
yeah he said that one all the richest
self-made woman worth four and a half
billion okay so what I say 34 that's not
even real who has that much like three
guys okay so she's worth four billion
that's still nothing this needs that I
got two bedroom apartment remember and
four I see a four is it your father who
is it who's hit in the past so this this
this thing the story when it came out
that all these people had invested
hundreds of millions of dollars into it
it made me think like do you imagine how
long it takes to make a hundred million
dollars to have a hundred million
dollars to invest in something that's
[ __ ] if you imagine like what it
must feel to find out that that [ __ ]
didn't work
look what like yeah you invested in a
scam it's all [ __ ] what yeah this is
they're being charged with massive fraud
no no yeah you're a hundred million
dollars is gone what what the [ __ ] did
you just say you're hundred million
dollars is gone they just got arrested
she got charged with massive fraud what
she's in prison keep happening on the in
the crypto market with i ce o--'s
initial coin offering so what's called
people will make some sort of pitch and
pitch people that their new startup is
worth it and instead of taking invest
their money they take cryptocurrency if
you will and then after they gain a
bunch that just disappear whoa it
happens almost every week now exit
scammers run off with 660 million in ICO
earnings see this is like what you were
saying about the Nigerian people getting
online and them not knowing certain
scams and then we get it's like scammers
find a way into every system mm-hmm
there's not tons of scams out there
they're just getting repurposed you know
that just another trick they just put a
little twist on it change the name and
it's a new scam yes it's all the same
scams I show you might want what you
want to know my pistol scam postal yeah
I've actually never done this but it's
like were you arrested for what you're
about to say well I don't know
I think carefully
okay well I've never drawn those
[ __ ] come down on you I've
never done it but this is something that
I I think somebody told me they used to
do in college I don't know I don't even
know if it really works but like I said
I got I wanted to send you a letter I
would put you as the yeah just switch to
return address in the send address throw
it in one of those blue mailboxes hey
they'll go hey no stamp return to sender
now I send it you that letter hmm
okay they probably know that one already
yeah they probably do yeah like a letter
though probably yeah yeah they're
probably what how'd it get all the way
over here today yeah they're smarter
than you bro
[Laughter]
[Applause]